latvia takes the penultimate step toward
joining euro single currency area this
week at talks in brussels EU finance and
economy ministers aim to adopt the last
three legislative files needed for the
Baltic state to join the euro climate
among their decisions The ministers will
rubber-stamp rules setting a permanent
conversion rate for the Latvian money
that lat against the euro it will all
pave the way for Latvia to become the
18th eurozone nation on january 1st 2014
during the meeting the council will
discuss the new Lithuanian presidencies
work program in economic and financial
affairs for the next six months while
keeping up Europe's focus on growth and
jobs the presidency has set further
development of the banking Union as a
key priority to help ensure EU financial
stability it regards the single
resolution mechanism for dealing with
failing banks as the next important step
in that process presidency also wants to
work toward ensuring sound transparent
and resilient financial markets and to
strengthen the protection of investors
in Europe other items on the minister's
agenda include the expected endorsement
of three documents for implementing the
so-called 2-pack of economic governance
rules